[Music]
my name is emily brown i'm 11 years old
i am finn wolfhard i'm sick i'm a boy
i'm 4 foot 11 i'm 12 years old
talk about a throwback a now 18 year old
millie bobby brown and 19 year old finn
wolfhard watched their and their
co-stars 2015 auditions during beyond
stranger things on netflix
look how depressed i look you look like
susan
et's been with the cast since their
award-winning show premiered back in
2016 and the 10 to 13 year olds were
suddenly thrust into stardom swear first
the most excellent promise you can make
this could be the most excellent promise
you can make most excellent promise you
can make
swearing i remember first reading the
script and i it was a great great tv
show but i never expected anything like
that it's just so much success and it's
crazy
yeah i mean i love the script i just
didn't know how fast it would go how how
overnight it would be
just a month and a half later the crew
of newcomers plus winona ryder and david
harper took home a screen actors guild
award you can't really take kids to
these events because they are going to
flip we freaked out i mean who was
expecting stranger things i know
am i weird
it's just sometimes
i feel i don't know
like like i'm
oh stuck god
then
what is the one thing that you guys
would like to see in season two of
stranger things i don't know if i'm
gonna be back um so it's very exciting
um if i am back and if not it's been a
great season well we all know how that
turned out the duffer brothers head back
into the writers room next week to start
work on season five nancy listen to me
listen listen this is probably the most
serious most important thing ever what
was your reaction for all of you when
you read the script and realize that the
the brothers are like kicking it up
another notch
you
have already lost
no
you have
i'm realizing more after the fact
after we filmed after we finished
everything up seeing the trailer come
out and seeing all the press releases
that's when it's finally
starting to sink in i think a little bit
more that this is uh by far the biggest
we've had yet open open
oh wow
[Music]
you